but we're going to begin once again in
Nashville after that horrific school
shooting there and horrific is still the
word we're learning more about the
victims today including nine-year-old
children Evelyn Dickhouse Hallie Scruggs
and William Kinney Covenant School head
that was Catherine Koontz and custodian
Mike Hill had been on the job 14 years
they say seven children and 14
grandchildren substitute teacher Cynthia
Peak all of these people were lost to
violence on a day lightly made more
lethal by the type of weapons involved
now let's go to our lead National
correspondent that's David begno who's
on the ground in Nashville I know David
we're learning more about the story and
it's still just as bad as We Know
it is Gail good morning we are learning
more specifically about those weapons
the suspect Audrey Hale identified by
that name by police legally bought seven
Firearms over the last few years at five
different stores now Hale's parents
found one gun they say and forced her to
sell it but they claimed they didn't
know about the other weapons three of
those guns were used in the Monday
morning Massacre including two assault
style weapons Janet shamlian has won the
investigation including that harrowing
body camera footage which is incredibly
intense to watch absolutely David good
morning to you is a video showing how
quickly officers acted as soon as they
arrived at the school racing inside
without hesitation running towards the
gunfire Nashville police this morning
being hailed for that response in
contrast to the widely criticized
response at Uvalde elementary school
last year this morning we have that
Nashville video for you but a warning it
is disturbing
after arriving at the Covenant School in
Nashville let's go several officers
including Rex Engelbert and Michael
Collazo raced inside
methodically checking classroom to
classroom guns drawn with the fire alarm
blaring
an officers pinpoint where the gunfire
is coming from
[Music]
when they reach the second floor they
run toward the sound of the gunshots
then they open fire
the suspect's motive is unknown I was
really impressed that with all that was
going on the danger that somebody took
control and said let's go let's go let's
go Adriana
and says Hale messaged her minutes
before the shooting warning that
something bad was about to happen
and then I screenshot it to my dad and I
was like uh do I need to say something
he takes back yes she says she contacted
authorities but it was too late
other stories from that day are emerging
too actress Melissa Joan Hart whose
children attend a school close to the
shooting said she and her husband helped
a class of kindergartners they were
climbing out of the woods they were
trying to escape
the shooter situation at their school so
we helped all these tiny little little
kids across the road and get their
teachers over there and we helped a mom
reunite with her children and um
I just I I don't know what to say
anymore it is just enough is enough
the actress added that she once lived in
Connecticut near where the Sandy Hook
massacre happened
just one more person speaking out about
how gun violence has followed them David
Janet thank you